Essam Jason McGee CTO for IBM cloud
platform I'm Chris wind I'm the CEO and
co-founder of logged unity so great to
be here with you Chris I think Eric just
got a chance to talk about our
partnership and what we're doing why
don't you kick off with you know tell us
a little bit about log DNA and what you
guys do and then we'll talk about kind
of our partnership together absolutely
thanks for having me this is a super fun
moment log DNA we help developers and
engineers DevOps seems monitor debug
their production issues we aggregate all
the logs with us from servers or LS
platforms and we put into a powerful
platform that gives you a lot of full
visibility into your structure which is
pretty fun that's great yeah so you know
that I've been cloud we're trying to
build this platform for developers and
and logging and observability are so
important for developer productivity and
so you and I started working together a
few years ago and to kind of combine the
best of what you guys were doing and
bring it to the IBM cloud platform it's
purely interesting during why don't you
tell me a little bit about like growth
that you guys have seen every year it's
been also like we as a blur awesome
constantly I love being a customer yes
and we see the scale and the flexibility
that it made perfect sense when we met
two years ago your world in our world
goes head and a head right and it's nice
when we we were big believers in
multi-cloud we're big believes in Cooper
Nettie's and it's nice that the best we
made two years ago actually paid off and
it's actually the future will be think
about the other right I think what was
nice is the simplicity of I being cloud
Nash our simplicity what we think about
simple is also powerful from a usability
perspective from a scale from a search
and it's very seamless that's the best
part is there I hate the developers and
IBM cloud with the power of log DNA so
it's a great win-win scenario yeah I
mean so let's talk about kind of you as
a client of IBM cloud you know one of
the things that attracted me to log in a
really two things one was this
incredible user experience that you guys
have built around developer need for
understanding their environments and two
especially two or three years ago very
forward-looking on kubernetes as a
platform for running things so
you know what's worked well for you on
IBM cloud and what you know what do you
like about it
I think simplicity scale so when we
think about scale we we do a lot okay I
don't know
full information but we do a lot and we
have a pretty lean team that could
manage that yeah I scale so I think
nowadays with the power of kubernetes
you don't have to maintain it as much
right so like there was like I think you
mentioned that 70/30 rule yeah in the
past of you know 7% is spent on
maintaining infrastructure it's a flip
now right and we love that so it allowed
us to deploy log in a on your
infrastructure pretty efficiently and
from a customer perspective it's easy to
use and it matches with the best out
there so we love it and we're super
proud to be to call ourselves customers
yeah and you one of the things I think
is really interesting is they take
logging as a as a use case it's not
maybe what people typically think of
with kubernetes you know it's very
data-intensive lots of information high
in just rates and then logs coming in a
lot of processing not where people
really started with kubernetes any
struggles they're like no you feel that
like you know I'm doing something on the
edge or you know did it I think we
always had the foresight of the volume
is growing exponentially so when you
think about that we had to think about
building a platform that's able to
ingest that well right store search it
the second is because of the complexity
we knew the complexity because of DevOps
containers kubernetes it's gonna be
complex and the day as we fragmented so
how do we make it simple and and I think
our user experience is always magical
and it should always feel that way right
and the third was like one size doesn't
fit all so how do you capture the right
platform for developers versus DevOps
versus security and that is hard to do
and it was a lot of foresight so we
didn't like I think we just hit her
four-year birthday and we had that first
force out of like it should be a
beautiful product and less is more so
you're up and running with kubernetes to
command lines right which is pretty
quick right and you yesterday yeah which
is awesome and that's how I should
always feel like you have other things
to focus on your priorities at us
handling the infrastructure monitoring
aspect observability should be our core
focus right that's the
benefit of IBM yeah so let's talk about
our partnership a little bit so well
again it plays an important role for IBM
you know you are the embedded logging
solution within our cloud yes and you
know I think you and I have done a lot
of work together to try to make that a
seamless experience for our users our
joint users you know one of the ways
that I tried to push our partnership is
IBM being a client of yours as well
whoo right we have this kind of joint
relationship which I think is really
powerful and we use Ogden a tremendously
within the cloud team and other parts of
IBM which I love to run our own systems
yes site and I think that's taught us a
lot about you know how to operate at
scale you've pushed in any service hard
which is which has been good as well
talk to me a little bit about kind of
the partnership angle and kind of how
its benefited you guys it's such a
win-win scenario so a we're customers of
mine in cloud second we get to embed om
our product to your customer base right
and your customers happens in two folds
it's your customers that you have but
also iBM is their own customer right and
it's such a it's such an honor when we
see scale and that's the word that
resonates oh yeah and the reason why you
have scale is is customers like hit
Watson uses us weather weather channel
uses right and it's not it's a lot of
logs right yeah they be able to handle
that infra which just talks about so
much of like Enterprise ready product
yeah right not just for IBM but for
IBM's customers as well and just it
doesn't get more confidence there versus
the other options that were out there
yeah one of my personal favorite moments
is when I was at the Masters last year
and walking through the Operations
Center that IBM runs to run that event
and and seeing the team there on the
ground could I'd never met using log DNA
using IBM cloud and kind of leveraging
that is how they ran abandon all on
their own self service there's kind of
consumed up that's amazing that so we're
seeing a lot of just internal teams
using it just because it's easy if you
have been running within minutes yeah
and that's how it should always be but
also the data that you're capturing and
the value of setting alerts it's a lot
of flexibility that we think for first
and for most of our product and it
jointly collapse pretty well yeah so
what's next
what
what do you like it a big thing that you
think you guys are focused on next that
we can go do together I think when we
talk about like open chef is a great
opportunity yeah we talking Kyle packs
is a great opportunity and it's ice up
the technology our technology is aligned
super line with with your future path
and it comes down to execution I think
being a lean team yeah we get to focus
on what matters the most but most
importantly our core DNA has always been
developers and it's what developers want
how do they got the speed and how do you
just get them hooked so that we can land
expand over time yeah and that's the new
movement that we both shared together
which is amazing yeah I loved I loved
the lean team I remember when we first
met and yeah I have this really small
fame in like the amount that I think we
all lose sight sometimes of you know
with cloud with public cloud with
technologies like you Bernays but with
all these things we were so used to
talking about we were excited like how
much people are able to accomplish small
teams I'm using this it was awesome
a great communication between the teams
it was just a vote of confidence both
ways because the fact that IBM was
forward-thinking to say who do you
partner with and also the fact that we
were able to showcase our technology
from scale as one perspective
flexible deployment I also love that
we're fully compliant okay yeah it's OPI
DGP are sought to HIPAA we were ready
yeah and then it doesn't get better
alignment then having the right over
left okay especially with died PM's kind
of focused customer base regulated
industries that were in like that was
really critical that that layer of the
platform which which can contain a lot
of sensitive data absolutely like met
those requirements around was really
great for us and I think we get to
collaborate of what our future are our
UI UX looks like right I look forward to
how do you create predictive graphs so
instead of teams walking in setting up
their own graphs if we know it's
kubernetes here's a five grass you need
to know right
and here's where do you want the alerts
being sense okay we always think about
building that magical moments and this
should feel magical when when developers
use us yeah well of course I really
appreciate the partnership that we've
had I'm excited for what we're doing I
think klog DNA is really proven to be a
powerful platform for our customers
absolutely um and I'm excited for us to
continue to collaborate together
thanks for collaborating and
we're just getting started at this part
great and for everybody else you know go
check out walk DNA I'm walking a comm or
come to IBM cloud and and check out the
offerings that we have there thank you
very much thank you